[Musique]
et si vous faites
vous allez voir
le soutien scolaire c'est d'habitude du
français des maths de la physique le
centre excellent soutien scolaire a
profité des vacances pour expérimenter
un nouvel atelier à une dizaine de
collégiens et lycéens le thème coaching
et réussit on a pu débattre en étant à
l'aise on a travaillé sur le fil aux
objectifs et m il est à nouveau passé de
me lever plus tôt pour être en bonne
forme toute la journée ont relâché un
peu la pression n'est plus on est plus à
l'écouté finalement parce que un élève
qui est voilà demain j'ai un contrôle la
semaine prochaine j'ai un devoir à
rendre donc il a un peu pris dans sa
tête de faire ça et en plus un début de
vacances on sait que il a un peu coupé
avec l'école et je trouve ça bien
justement de profiter de cette coupure
pour aller parler d'autre chose en toute
tranquillité finalement parmi les axes
des trois heures de travail de la
matinée lutter contre ces croyances
limitantes une barrière mentale qui nous
empêche d'entreprendre ou de rêver pour
les mathématiques on est très souvent
conditionnés à ne pas y arriver parce
que depuis tout petit on entend que les
maths c'est quelque chose super dur
super compliqué tout ça ce sont des
croyances limitantes il y avait un élève
qui me disait moi j'aimerais bien gagner
dix mille euros par mois mais toute
façon je sais que je pourrai pas ça
c'est une croyances limitantes pourquoi
tu te dis déjà à treize ans que tu
pourras pas gagné dix mille euros par
mois c'est pas possible
les élèves ont ainsi pu se construire
une liste d'objectifs de vie à court et
long terme afin de trouver la motivation
et une raison pour mieux travailler je
sais pertinemment que les objectifs qui
vont se fixer maintenant à 13 14 voire
15 ans ne seront peut-être pas ce qu'ils
auront à 25 ou 30 ans pour moi ce qui
est important c'est qu'il en est un
c'est important quand vous jouez dans
votre jeu vidéo de savoir quel est le
but du jeu sinon c'est la meilleure
façon de perdre le centre excellent
soutien scolaire souhaite mettre en
place d'autres ateliers de ce genre et
des activités extrascolaires comme le
codage ou la sensibilisation à des
domaines d'études peu connue des jeunes